[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 dossiers
aujourd'hui focus sur l'agriculture
yvelinoise alors que vient de se tenir
le salon international de paris
avec 39 % de surfaces agricoles près de
1000 exploitations les yvelines sont le
deuxième département de l'agriculture
francilienne
nous sommes allés à la rencontre
d'agriculteurs yvelinois des jeunes tout
juste installé jusqu'à la ferme de
viltain qui participait à son 30e salon
de l'agriculture
nous allons aussi découvrir dans cette
série de reportages à suivre de
nouvelles pratiques agricoles comme la
ferme en ville
regardez
imaginez une ancienne décharge
transformée en ferme
c'est le pari un peu fou mais réussie de
l'association le vivant et la ville en
2014 elle a créé le premier
démonstrateur d'agriculture urbaine de
france c'est un démonstrateur parce que
sa vocation d'être dupliqué sur d'autres
sites délaissé la particularité c'est
que tout est hors sol par nature même
des sols qui sont qui sont pollués ou
contraint toutes les technologies
agricoles sont développés au dessus du
sol
là vous ou situé dans la zone de
production et ont produit des fraises
des framboises et tomates cerises qu'on
va ensuite en circuit court et c'est
l'intérêt de faire des fermes en ville
c'est de pouvoir alimenter l'ensemble
des populations qui vivent aujourd'hui
la plupart du temps en ville une
ancienne friche de près de 4 hectares
devenu un jardin d'éden
l'hiver les équipes préparent les beaux
jours ils viennent d'aménager la culture
des fraises se fit là il vient protéger
des insectes bien protégé du vent il a
pas mal de fonctions thermique mais on a
décidé de réinstaller c'est la première
fois qu'on le fait cette année un tunnel
plastique dessous pour gagner en
précocité et pour
commencer plus tôt dans la saison
avantage du hors sol l'eau qui n'est pas
absorbée par les plantes et récupérer
pour être réinjectés une économie non
négligeable pour cette denrée précieuse
les particuliers peuvent aussi jouer les
apprentis maraîchers depuis 2015 la
ferme en ville s'est lancée dans la
location de jardin si vous souhaitez
louer un jardin vous disposez d'un
morceau de cabanes ou d'une malle en
fonction de l'option vous prenez et
ensuite 50 mètres carrés vous avez deux
bacs et demi cela correspond à peu près
à 25 mètres carrés de culture avec un
cours de jardinage par mois une
irrigation automatique qui vous
j'enlève l'astreinte de l'arrosage ce
qui est en soi un confort qui est pas du
tout négligeable
vous cultivez hors sol du coup vous êtes
en hauteur vous avez moins de vous
blesser et c'est une manière de
sensibiliser le grand public
depuis deux saisons l'intérêt des
citadins pour ce dispositif se manifeste
de plus en plus aujourd'hui 50 % des
abonnés vient de saint germain en laye
boulogne même paris on pense que
l'avenir de l'agriculture urbaine
ce sera probablement une filière
multifonctionnel associer des métiers
qui sont complémentaires
à voir à la fois des métiers de service
comme typiquement la location de jardin
et des métiers de production comme ce
qu'on voit ici autour de nous une zone
qui est dédiée à la production
professionnelle pour ensuite vendre
cette production pour pouvoir fournir
les urnes en circuit court
chaque année la ferme en ville crée des
emplois saisonniers pour s'occuper des
cultures elles produites en moyenne 12 à
13 tonnes de fruits et légumes par an
elle espère arriver à 18 ans dans
quelques années
des cochons des vaches des moutons près
de 3200 bêtes sont mises à l'honneur au
salon international de l'agriculture
et parmi ces animaux des ovins yvelinois
les mérinos de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet c'était des mérinos au
départ et comme il séjourne depuis plus
de deux siècles à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet bas ils ont été
rebaptisés mérinos de rambouillet je
participe au jugement des concours de
races ovines sur la qualité des toisons
en tant qu'expert lainiers auprès du
concours général agricole il ya des
critères qui sont communes à toutes les
races notamment loge vérité c'est qu'on
essaye de rechercher une fibre qui a la
même finesse
depuis les pôles où elle est la plus
fine jusqu'aux hugo où est la plus
grossière prenons de la hauteur pour
rencontrer les producteurs pour sa
deuxième présence sur le salon
la ferme des à lui ai fait découvrir ses
légumes anciens des visiteurs étonnés
face à des produits comme le choucas lé
la poire de terre ou la racine de
personnes grippées ça se mange pas
ou cuits comme une pomme de terre poids
ça
les gens passent 1
nous posent des questions à bastien
c'est vrai comme salsifis je pensais pas
que ça pue c'est comme ça en plus on les
éduque un petit peu on leur explique
comment le cultiver même les gens qui
sont qui viennent du sud de la france
ils disent 'voilà tient au salon on a vu
des légumes dans l'île de france qui
était formidable pour ce salon
international de l'agriculture 2010 est
les organisateurs attendent plus de 620
mille visiteurs jusqu'au dimanche 5 mars
[Musique]
comme chaque matinée d'hiver nicolas
jossier prend son tracteur des actions
ses champs de céréales pour contrôler
les semences face aux menaces de la
période hivernale notamment les
mauvaises herbes les insectes ici à un
vule pas mais comme on peut le voir on
les a traités à l'automne et le produit
agit là la plante est en train d'être
détruites pour l'instant l'implantation
des céréales et est excellente donc nous
allons croiser les doigts pour que la
météo soit avec nous et et nous prônons
procure le soleil et l'eau qu'il faut
pour mener à bien nos cultures en fait
blé orge colza cette exploitation
familiale et basés de plus près d'un
siècle au village de prenez en yvelines
à 33 ans nicolas chossy a décidé de
reprendre cette ferme qui s'est installé
le 1er septembre 2016 et souhaite
utiliser son expérience professionnelle
dans sa nouvelle activité
j'ai été boulanger mais pâtissier
pendant 15 ans tout en travaillant
l'après-midi avec mon père sur
l'exploitation pour l'est pour lui
donner un coup de main donc j'ai
toujours eu l'amour de la terre et la
ferme familiale
j'espère pouvoir me diversifier
justement en comment dire en combinant
mon métier antérieures c'est à dire le
métier de boulanger
c'est à dire valoriser mon blé en farine
et enfin classement de factures
signature de documents le travail
administratif est important lors d'une
installation une procédure rendue
compliquée aussi par la conjoncture
agricole les difficultés de deux prix
des marchés des céréales qui sont qui
sont au plus bas depuis quelques années
ce qui fragilise
comment dire notre notre trésorerie la
moisson 2016 qui a été catastrophique en
tâches encore cette trésorerie par
contre c'est vrai que on peut compter
sur sur nos partenaires
d'approvisionnement
en ce moment sans produits
phytosanitaires en engrais pour nous
aider à traverser cette mauvaise passe
quoi et 2016 n'a pas été favorable à
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
certains ont décidé de repousser leurs
démarches
en attendant une période plus stable
pour le secteur agricole
les vaches du salon de l'agriculture en
raffole le point fabrique et à la ferme
de viltain à jouy en josas un produit à
base de graines de tiges et de feuilles
de maïs
réalisé à partir de la récolte de
l'année dernière 5 tonnes sont livrés
chaque jour sur le salon de
l'agriculture
et y'a rien à dire les vaches il est il
est froid il ap temps il est il reste
une matière sèche correct pour la base
d'idées il faut que ce soit consommé
frais donc on peut pas aller venir
chercher sa du centre de la france
comme on est la ferme la plus près de
paris va ils sont très contents et nous
on cultive plus de maïs parce qu'on sait
qu'on va avoir 300 vaches au salon à
nourrir pendant une semaine en plus de
nourrir les bêtes la ferme de viltain
est présente depuis trente ans sur le
salon à son stand activités pédagogiques
et dégustation attire de nombreux
visiteurs
c'est vraiment un grand moyen à prendre
bien sûr tout le domaine des animaux ce
qu'ils mangent
elle peut toucher même si c'est interdit
elle peut toucher donc c'est très
agréable
on a fait beaucoup de jeu
on a fait beaucoup de dégustation qui on
a vu des animaux c'est l'occasion pour
nous de 20 de rencontrer des clients des
clients de
qui achète peut-être toute l'année nos
produits
et ont l'occasion de les manger aussi
dans leur restaurant d'entreprise
et qui sont content de le retrouver ici
du cou qui voit vraiment l'agriculteur
c'est l'occasion de leur dire vous
pouvez venir à la ferme et une ferme pas
très loin de paris il n'est à 17km
venait de rencontrer ni voir la traite
des vaches à partir du lait de ses
vaches l'exploitation de jouy en josas
fabrique ses yaourts et d'autres
produits laitiers on a mis dans le fonds
de la confiture et par dessus du yaourt
légèrement sucrées quand on mélange est
bas ou fait soi même
manger un petit peu dit au cna tuera
promet un peu plus de confiture etc
c'est un peu ludique confiture de lait
c'est du lait du sucre cuit ensemble
pendant
quatre heures avec de l'avenir
le laisse se réduisent caramélise
devient marron et ça fait une batte à
tartiner pour cette édition 2010 est la
ferme de viltain reçu une médaille
d'argent et deux médailles de bronze
pour trois de ses yaourts
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
le site internet ou sur l'application
mobile de tv fil 78
rendez vous fin mars pour un nouveau 7 8
dossiers
[Musique]